[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com all right so this is where
normally I put up the dozens of emails
that I get saying things like David I
can tell that you are a shill for
Elizabeth Warren because when her
polling goes up you talk about it but
when her polling goes down you don't
talk about it or David I can tell you
hate Bernie because when Bernie's
polling goes up you don't talk about it
and when Bernie's polling goes down you
gleefully talk about it and of course
none of that's true
but when you look at the facts the truth
is we've had essentially six straight
months of Bernie's polling going more or
less know where he was at 14 in late
April and he was at 14 three weeks ago
well we've had six straight months of
Elizabeth Warren's polling climbing from
eight in April to as high as twenty
seven a couple of weeks ago I just tell
you what is happening and for the first
time in many months
Bernie's polling is showing signs of
life so is Pete Buddha judges but we'll
get to that shortly and it's happening
at the expense of Joe Biden and
Elizabeth Warren let's look at the
numbers for which I am of course merely
a humble messenger not the pollster as
you can see at the top of the graph
declines for Joe Biden and Elizabeth
Warren Joe Biden down about two and a
half points in the last three weeks
Elizabeth Warren also losing some
momentum down about five points in the
last three weeks who is gaining in the
last three weeks well it's Bernie and
also Pete Budaj edged you see Bernie the
blue line popping up from about 14 to
now more than 17 a three point gain for
Bernie you also see the purple line on
the graph this is Pete boo
mayor Pete from South Bend Indiana
climbing from just about four points a
couple of weeks ago now polling about 7%
this is the highest Pete Buddha judge
has pulled since early May otherwise
things are basically unchanged Kamala
Harris continuing a more or less slow
decline since early July everything else
really not not much else going on with
her
Andrew yang still has his two-and-a-half
average Tulsi Gabbard has her one point
three average Beto still has around two
and klobuchar around two so what do we
make of all this well bernie is still in
it that's what we make of it Bernie's
doing what he has to do if he wants a
shot at this thing gaining back some of
the support that he lost all the way
back in April when Joe Biden entered
this race if you were supporting Bernie
you should be pleased he did what he had
to do in the last three weeks which is
he picked up three points in three weeks
now with the debate number five coming
up he has to keep it going and it's
particularly important because we have
this fifth debate coming up on November
20th it is an opportunity conceivably
hypothetically for someone to make a big
showing and make a gain in the polls but
as I said when I appeared on PBS a
couple of weeks ago the further into the
primary we get the less that there is to
gain from having a good debate showing
because the candidates positions are
known the candidates personalities are
known the candidates presences presences
that's a difficult word to say their
presences on the stage are known because
they've been around for longer and we've
been watching a whole bunch of debates
so far so the further we get into this
thing the debates actually represent a
potential liability the the debates
represent an opportunity to do something
wrong and to lose support in the polls
the downside of the debates becomes
bigger as we get further into it
particularly because there is less time
to make up for missteps while the
possibility of some big gain due to the
debates diminishes so that
it's just a reality that's not about
Bernie specifically now for debate
number five we have nine people already
qualified we have Beto Tulsi and Julian
Castro pending some of the requirements
so we could conceivably end up with 12
people on the debate stage again which I
guess it diminishes the speaking time
for each person which in a sense reduces
the possibility that they make some
major ghafir faux pas and put their foot
in their mouth but once again we are not
going to get deep discussion about any
issue quite frankly from a debate that
has 12 people up on the stage the
qualification period for debate 5 which
is on November 20th ends on November
13th a week before so they basically
have two weeks left to either be in or
out
Beto Tulsi and Julio Castro
so we will see ultimately who makes that
stage Bernie Sanders people who are
following Bernie supporting Bernie
should be pleased a point a week I mean
listen Elizabeth Warren got to her peak
of 27 point whatever it was gaining
about a point and a half to two points a
month so a point a week is a lot we
haven't had polls for about five days
and I'm guessing by tomorrow we'll have
some new ones and we will see how Bernie
is doing there okay one of the big
criticisms or concerns or really fake
concerns from concern trolls about the
Donald Trump impeachment inquiry has
been the impeachment inquiry has not
been formalized there is no roadmap to
what it is that Nancy Pelosi and
Democrats are doing and as a result
there is no due process afforded to
Donald Trump it's all bogus
but even that talking point is about to
fall apart because the house is going to
be voting on formalizing the roadmap and
the next steps of the Trump impeachment
inquiry which is an increasingly popular
impeachment inquiry with the American
people as we've been talking about for
the last three weeks we anticipate that
this is going to be introduced
today maybe it's already been introduced
or even voted on by the time you watch
this clip or listen to today's show will
they be uniting under the umbrella of
harassing Donald Trump no will they
officially announce the start of a
witch-hunt
gimme a break this is a formal process
which will spell out the rights that a
president has during an impeachment
inquiry it will spell out the role that
Donald Trump's attorneys can play and a
bunch of other processes so what's the
real meaning of this it is to set up a
framework so that Trump can't or at
least would look stupid to continue
insisting that this is a
constitutionally invalid inquiry that
it's a violation of his due process
Trump has been pulling these stunts for
a while now and of course they're absurd
impeachment inquiries by the house are
constitutionally delineated never mind
valid but still formally authorizing an
inquiry with its guideposts and
establishing what due process will look
like is a good thing because we live in
the United States and this is how we do
things now this is going to pressure
Republicans to cooperate it's not going
to force them to cooperate congressman
ro Khanna friend of the show yesterday
was saying this will further put
pressure on Republicans to just
cooperate with the inquiry they may
still be in the same place in two weeks
which is ignoring subpoenas ignoring
subpoenas for documents and at that
point we will go back to what is very
quickly becoming the most prominent and
sort of foremost issue in this
impeachment inquiry will Democrats at
least attempt to enforce their
investigative and subpoena power or will
Republicans and Donald Trump get away
with ignoring it all again and again and
again and ultimately this is going to be
another point in the process which will
simply be spun by trumpets trumpets are
already saying I saw them on reddit this
morning why are all these steps and
votes being put in place
it seems so forced and consider the
absurdity of this first they said you
know the problem is this thing's not
formal enough it's a wacky witch hunt
there's no limits it's
no holds barred and now Democrats want
to formalize it and put some limits and
some structure around it and those same
trumpets are saying oh this is so forced
boats delineating exactly what they this
is just too much it's too forced this is
why we can't listen to them and this is
why Democrats just need to do what they
need to do the point I'm anxiously
awaiting are the public hearings the
evidence being released the day after
day tweet storms that no doubt Donald
Trump will be going on the possibility
of I mean imagine Rudy Giuliani
testifying but you need to enforce
subpoenas yes Rudy if you force him to
show up we'll say I don't recall to
every question he will say on the advice
of counsel I am invoking my Fifth
Amendment privilege against the
self-incrimination or eminent privilege
he will do all of those things but you
still need to enforce subpoenas or this
entire thing ends up being just a
pathetic waste of time
don't make it a waste of time Democrats
please don't make it a waste of time and
I let me just riad ress this point a few
people even though I discussed this
yesterday I still got emails from people
saying David Democrats can try to
enforce subpoenas but still nothing
might happen
okay well let's cross that bridge when
we come to it at least try to enforce
the subpoenas by every legal and law
enforcement means that is available to
you to say you're putting the cart
before the horse it's a big metaphor day
you're putting the cart before the horse
to say it doesn't matter if Democrats
try to enforce the subpoenas because
Republicans will get away with ignoring
them anyway it's different to get away
with ignoring them after Democrats have
actually tried to enforce the subpoenas
then merely to say Republicans got away
with ignoring the requests and nothing
else happened we are going to be
following this we will see really how
this is all structured in the vote that
Nancy Pelosi plans to put forward in the
House of Representatives very very soon
make sure you're following me on Twitter
at D Pakman and while you're on Twitter
following me follow the show at David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be back right
this the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are wendy zir Foss and kingsley mag
POC Wendy and Kingsley thank you so much
for being David Pakman show members I
really do appreciate your support and I
hope you'll stay with us 5 years like
today's sustaining member of the day has
done Jason Miller today's longtime
sustainer of the day with us almost 5
years thanks to all of you great folks
we will be extra counting on your
support as we get into the the bulk of
the 2020 election particularly the
general election where we will be hoping
to expand and do all sorts of new things
but it will depend on audience support
sign up in under a minute
at join pakman.com coupon code is
available this is 20/20 all one word all
lowercase it'll save you 40% you still
get all the good stuff including daily
access to the members only bonus show
now hosted on Fridays by producer Pat
I'm still hosting Monday through
Thursday we have today a second story
that serves as a really good case study
and the propaganda cycles that are often
started by President Trump but then
perpetuated by Fox News which gets them
into the ecosystem and generates these
default reflexive talking points that we
end up hearing for years from the Trump
astride despite being completely wrong
and free of any facts and I'm going to
explain this entire thing to you we
actually have a couple of propaganda
cycle stories for you today there is a
White House national security official
named Alexander vind Minh Binh Minh is a
whistleblower VIN Minh says he heard the
phone call where Donald Trump pushed the
Ukrainian president to investigate
Trump's political opponents like Joe
Biden how VIN Minh is set to testify
before Congress which is going to be
extraordinarily explosive testimony we
are talking about
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh a
veter a vet 'add that is national
security official
a military veteran and Donald Trump has
previously suggested that whistleblowers
the people going to the whistleblowers
with information that they are basically
spies and Donald Trump alluded to
treason he alluded to the execution of
such treasonous spies and last night on
Fox News's Laura Ingraham program a real
doozy of a show it was suggested that
what Alexander vind Minh did is
espionage and that VIN Minh might even
be I hope you're sitting for this one a
Ukrainian double agent check this out
and pay attention to whether you
recognize the person making this
argument this is buried in the New York
Times piece tonight but I found it very
interesting
he's a decorated colonel by the way in
the Iraq war but because Colonel Vin de
Minh emigrated from Ukraine along with
his family when he was a child and his
fluent in Ukrainian and Russian
Ukrainian officials sought advice from
him about how to deal with mr. Giuliani
though they typically communicated in
English now wait a second John here we
have a US national security official who
is advising Ukraine while working inside
the White House apparently against the
president's interest and usually they
spoke in English isn't that kind of an
interesting angle on this story
I find that astounding and you know some
people might call that espionage but it
doesn't actually seem to add any new
facts to what we know if you know in
terms of I think Alan raises a good
point is this a high crime in
misdemeanor
whether you have one person or five
people all saying well we objected to
what the president said with the
president of Ukraine we have the
transcript of the call we can all make
our judgment I don't see how this
breaking news actually adds more facts
to what we know about whether this is an
impeachable offense or not so if the guy
suggesting this looks familiar that's
John you he's the guy who imploded when
questioned by
late john conyers when asked whether he
thinks that legally the president could
have a suspect buried alive and he does
one of the greatest lawyer non answers
may be in congressional testimony
history where he says i've never
recommended to a president that they
have a suspect buried alive no no but
but counselor you could the president do
that i don't know why any president
would ever do that I know lots of
presidents no president would do that
this it for the young people in our
audience we're taking a brief departure
from the whistleblower thing this is a
classic clip of Bush administration
lawyer John you check it out
is there anything miss professor you
that the president could not order to be
done to a suspect if he believed it
necessary for national defense
well I mean I think that goes back to
the quote you just read because no I'm
just asking you to question maybe a
dozen that doesn't but what do you think
I think it's the same question that I
was asked or what's there's this kind
made clear I'm not talking about and you
don't have to make anything clear just
answer the question of counsel I just
want to make sure I'm not saying you
don't have to worry about that saying
just answer the question okay my
thinking right now yes right now am I
thinking right now this moment this
moment mr. chairman is that you know
first the question you're posing what is
the answer
it was try not trying to make you're
wasting too slowly could the president
order a suspect buried alive mr.
chairman I don't think that I have ever
I'm asking you that given the advice
that the president could bury somebody
alive I didn't ask
if you ever gave him advice I asked you
do you think the president could order a
suspect buried alive mister sure in my
view right now is that I don't think a
president would and no American
president would ever order that or feel
it necessary to order that yeah so that
guy thinks that the whistleblower might
be a spy Ukrainian double agent last
week I had a caller who said wait David
I thought Republicans were for military
veterans
I thought they supported the troops and
I explained to you that's only true when
it serves their political goals here's a
military veteran who they are smearing
as a spy because it doesn't serve their
political goals to say hey you know what
we respect the troops we support the
troops and if this guy is a veteran of
the American military then maybe we
should listen to what he has to say now
this may deliberately or accidentally
get Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh killed
this is serious stuff or they are doing
okay when you have someone that Donald
Trump who is looked up to as a deity by
trumpets say the whistle blowers may be
spies or treasonous that's already
endangering their lives when you then
perpetuate the propaganda on the echo
chamber that is Fox News with John you
saying this guy could be a double agent
this guy could be working for Ukraine
you are literally endangering this man's
life now they are now as predicted
shifting to attacking the whistleblower
and the whistleblowers character to get
their base fired up and to shift the
focus off of what Trump did to how we
found out about it this is a very common
tactic that to be perfectly frank is
often employed by the left and the right
when you have a leak or a whistle being
blown if you like the content you focus
on the content if you don't you focus on
how we found out about it and isn't it
terrible how this information went
public that the left and right does this
VIN Minh importantly the
is blowing the whistle to protect our
country against Donald Trump who is
putting our national security at risk
our sovereignty at risk and the way that
this fits into the propaganda cycle is
that the trumpets will chug this
nonsense like it's being ladle fed to
them and it will become the go-to
talking point the whistle blower you're
talking about the spy Ukrainian double
agent who is a treasonous whatever
charge him right away really dangerous
times that we're living in and this one
is really simple to understand espionage
has a very specific definition
politically spying to obtain political
and military information well what do we
mean by spying is just hearing something
spying know spying is work for a
government or organization done by
secretly collecting information about
enemies or competitors
lieutenant-colonel vin Minh works for
the US and blew the whistle in the u.s.
because he's worried about how Donald
Trump is hurting the u.s. that's not
espionage that's not treason it's none
of the above it's really important we
understand it because they are putting
people's lives at risk let's go now to
part two of our study of how the
trumpian fox news propaganda cycles work
this next story is a story that in a
normal world on a normal planet would
not be a story but in the story of
donald trump's 2019 reality this is a
very real story Fox and Friends has been
caught editing out and minimizing the
booing and the chanting of lock him up
that took place during donald trump's
brief appearance at Game five of the
World Series over the weekend so to
remind you yesterday I played for you a
bunch of clips of Trump showing up in
Washington DC for Game five of the World
Series and the entire place booing him
as soon as he appeared on screen
chanting lock him up and Trump visibly
grimacing when he realized that that's
what taking that's what's taking place
the real world is not the echo chamber
filter bubble of his carefully curated
rallies that he's been doing we
talked about that yesterday here is Fox
and Friends yesterday with the booing
notably missing I'm going to do audio
only here because there is footage in
this video of the of copy written
content Major League Baseball is
extraordinarily aggressive so I'm just
gonna be doing audio here let's take a
very quick listen to this because the
President and First Lady were at the
game last night they got there right
around the time that it started and they
stayed a pretty long time they were
greeted with Miss mixed reaction but
they were out there smiling waving to
everybody as you can see in the crowd so
that's what happened right around game
time let's take it to the top of the
second inning right now and show you
some of that action
Alvarez hits a two-run home run that yes
so then they just get into highlights
from the game it was all great fun and I
love how she calls it mixed reaction
which might be true only in the most
technical sense but this was a crowd
that was very hostile to the President
of the United States they did not want
Donald Trump there that is the sort of
bigger truth that Fox and Friends can't
or won't tell their audience reminder
this is what was going on yesterday
[Music]
and then of course the chance of lock
him up
breakout here's another part of the
stadium also chanting lock him up
[Applause]
so this is not in and of itself the most
important story but it's a really
important story to understand the
propaganda cycle this is the
continuation of the propaganda cycle
Trump goes through the game nobody wants
him there they boo him they chant lock
him up and from clearly notices I mean
it's obvious that he notices then people
say booing I don't know I saw the video
this morning on Fox & Friends
I didn't see any booing anyone saying
that there was booing must be spreading
fake news what terrible people Donald
Trump is right about all the problems
with fake news out there and meanwhile
you have Fox and Friends cutting out the
booing calling it mixed reaction Trump
astana on the internet say it was
liberals who digitally added the booing
that wasn't really there and the cycle
just continues and perpetuates itself
people were joking when this happened
that this is exactly the way it would go
and it went exactly this way Fox cuts
out the booing and calls it mixed
reaction while Trump is spread
conspiracy theories that the booing was
digitally inserted by evil fake news
liberals how stupid does Fox News think
that their audience actually may be that
maybe that's not the right question to
be asking in any case we have a problem
here the self-perpetuating propaganda
cycle I realized that was going in a
direction that maybe is not the right
direction to go in we need to understand
it but we also need some way of fighting
it and unfortunately the symbiotic
relationship between Donald Trump's
talking points and the unflinching
followers that believe anything he says
as if it were gospel combined with Fox
News and the right-wing media that
helped to foment and expand and signal
boost these lies and disgusting depraved
talking points makes it really difficult
to fight against this stuff and this is
one of the things that is being pointed
out by people who were following
Watergate when it was going on and are
following what is going on right now
that is one of the primary differences
between Nixon and the 70s and Trump
right now which is that they both seem
to have done impeachable things they
both are tampering with witnesses they
both are
doing all of the same stuff but Nixon
didn't have something like Fox News and
the right-wing media cycle and circus
which Donald Trump has to his benefit
and that may ultimately be the
difference-maker in preventing public
opinion from completely turning against
on it from we will see make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram at david dot pack
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the David
Pakman show
hey this is just amazing as I like to
say you really can't write this stuff
Donald Trump's attorney or we think he
still may be his attorney rudy giuliani
butt-dialed a reporter and was overheard
talking about how he needs cash and
saying negative things about joe and
hunter biden now a butt-dial of course
for those uninitiated is when you have
your mobile phone in your pocket and it
unlocks and accidentally calls someone
and they pick up and they say hello
hello but they just hear whatever
conversation is taking place in the
background or wherever the caller is but
the best part is that this wasn't just
any but dial on October 16th Rudy
Giuliani butt-dialed a reporter for NBC
News named rich Shapiro Rudy had
actually spoken to Shapiro earlier the
same night so it might have been like a
redial of the most recent name or number
in the call log at 11:07 p.m. Rudy's
phone calls Shapiro's Shapiro was
sleeping it goes to voicemail and a
three-minute long voicemail is left now
often three minutes is the maximum
voicemail length before it automatically
stops recording that's at least the case
with the David Pakman show voicemail
number we have a lot of experience with
people calling and hitting that max and
then being cut off Rudy was talking to
someone else and he was talking about
needing cash
here Rudy say let's get back to business
I got a I gotta get you to get on
Bahrain Giuliani says at one point the
problem is we need some money there's
then nine seconds of silence and then
Rudy Giuliani says we need a few hundred
thousand rudy during this butt-dial
voicemail refers to robber several times
that could be Robert mangas Robert
mangas as a lawyer who happens to be a
registered agent on the behalf of the
Turkish government Rudy used to work for
the same law firm until about a year ago
um also fascinatingly this isn't even
the first time that Rudy Giuliani has
butt-dialed the same reporter last time
it happened he was trash-talking the
Biden's it was months ago and he had
said in the butt-dial things like Biden
has been trading in on his public office
since he was a senator going on to say
about hunter Biden when he became vice
president the kid decided to go around
the world and say hire me because I'm
Joe Biden's son and most people wouldn't
hire him because he had a drug problem
also saying his son altogether made
somewhere between five and eight million
a three million transaction was
laundered which is illegal as we've
referred to before this is stupid
Watergate stupid Watergate there's
stupidity and incompetence are matched
or exceeded only by the trumpet's who
are gullible enough to think that
everything is fine and everything is
normal I was thinking you know people
like to say who would play Trump if a
movie was made about this administration
would it be alec baldwin or would it be
somebody else if you make a film about
this administration how do you do it in
a way that doesn't appear to be a comedy
particularly for people decades from now
who maybe don't hadn't lived through
what it is that we are living through
today why do i constantly have to double
check to see if I'm reading the onion or
a satirical news website when I read
about what it is that people associated
with this administration are doing how
is Rudy Giuliani anyone
lawyer nevermind lawyer to the President
of the United States of America and what
so took to be serious for a moment here
what we learn from this butt-dial what
we learn from what this reporter heard
in the voicemail that was left is that
the Rudy Giuliani being involved with
trying to smear and go after the Biden
stuff has been going on for many many
months we've recently learned about this
we recently found out about the July 25
Ukraine phone call which was just a few
months ago this has been going on at
minimum since the beginning of 2019 or
close to it if not 2018 or even earlier
and the only thing that I want to know
is the full extent of how deep Rudy
Giuliani's involvement goes because it
is very clear that he is up to his
eyeballs in this stuff and we may never
know because no matter what subpoenas
Rudy Giuliani gets he may ignore them if
Democrats don't actually enforce those
subpoenas I hope we will someday learn
the full truth of it I'm not optimistic
that we will I've said before that the
issue of the minimum wage is a
complicated issue
I've been asked before would a $15
minimum wage nationally be good or bad
for the economy and the truth is that a
lot of the answer depends on where you
are measuring whether it's good or bad
for the economy and I've said this
before um you know we could stick the
talking points on this show and do black
and white stuff like everything is
either very good or very bad it's all
good or all bad that's not the reality
okay so when we think about a $15
minimum wage in lower cost of living
places where a $15 minimum wage might be
doubling the prevailing minimum wage
there could be negative effects in some
ways in terms of the destabilizing
effect that that could have on the local
job market etc that's a reality on the
other hand in high cost of living places
a $15 minimum wage may not even be
enough number one and number two is
unlikely to hurt the economy relative to
how much it will help people afford
their day to day lives and enjoy
more money into the wallets of workers
so we've got to be thoughtful here there
are some who say raising the minimum
wage has no negative impact period
that's not true I mean that's just not
true in all cases of course there are
people on the other side who say any
increase to the minimum wage causes
layoffs
it causes business closures it will blow
up the cost of everything because
businesses will just raise prices in
order to account for that but of course
that also isn't true today we have a new
case study from new york city new york
city raised the minimum wage to $15 an
hour
a year ago the restaurant industry which
is one of the ones that is often the
focus of minimum wage increases the
restaurant industry is doing really well
in New York City despite this New York
City restaurants have seen increased
revenue and they've also seen increased
employment now the way they've done it
is that prices have gone up slightly at
New York City restaurants detractors of
the minimum wage will immediately say
whoa whoa whoa you raise prices
customers will stop going out to eat the
businesses will fail they'll have to
fire everybody and the minimum wage
increase will backfire hasn't happened
and you know why prices don't have to go
up very much imagine that the minimum
wage goes up for example 8% and imagine
that restaurants account for that by
increasing food prices by 8% now more
than likely they wouldn't because the
labor costs are only part of what it
costs to run a restaurant so an 8%
increase in wages would not even require
an 8% increase in prices but ok
imagine that wages go up 8% food prices
go up 8% a $10 burger becomes 10 dollars
and 80 cents now I'm not gonna write
that off as nothing but for most people
you're not going to go out to eat a
different number of times because the
burger goes from 10 dollars to 10
dollars and 80 cents this is the reality
I don't want to be insensitive I don't
I'm not ignoring that 80 cents on a 10
dollar meal can be meaningful to men
people but the reality is that for the
most part you're not going to
drastically change your habits if your
burger goes from ten dollars to ten
dollars and 80 cents but on the other
side of the ledger everybody who works
at the restaurant and gets a raise
because of that minimum wage increase
now has more money to go out to other
restaurants and to patronize other
businesses where they live that is
hugely stimulative to the economy
overall now there's no question that if
the New York City economy starts to fail
because it's been a strong economy in
New York City for the last year if the
New York City economy starts to fail it
will be bad for lots of people it'll be
bad for restaurants it'll be bad for
their workers but in the economic
environment in New York City of the last
year the minimum wage increase has been
a very very positive thing now there are
also trickle up effects to having better
paid workers other than just they have
money to spend at local businesses they
are happier they have a higher standard
of living and thus are providing better
service which is good for the businesses
they may be able to afford living closer
to work because they can afford it or
having a more reliable car to get to
work becomes economically within reach
which makes them more reliable workers
and helps the business so it's really
important to think about these changes
systemically rather than myopically this
is not to pretend that the minimum wage
can be increased endlessly but no one is
proposing that this is a very common red
herring on the right where they'll say
listen if $15 an hour is better than 10
why not make the minimum wage $25 an
hour or $100 an hour or $200 an hour
then everybody will just have tons of
money right liberals well hold on a
second $100 an hour is not an
equilibrium wage $100 an hour is not a
wage that is the logical living wage
based on the cost of living of any
particular place in the United States of
America it is a distraction and it's
really important not to fall for it so
my sort of view on the left discussing
minimum wage increases is number one
don't let them set the talking
that we have to argue against with
stupid stuff like make the minimum wage
a hundred dollars an hour if you just
want people to make more money that's
stupid that that's not even worth
discussing but let's not be the ones
that pretend that there is not another
side to the ledger minimum wage
increases have effects they have trickle
up effects and they have trickle-down
effects we don't have to pretend that
there's no risk to a minimum wage
increase to be able to justify it as the
right policy in many cases and in many
instances that's the approach I think
that the left should have and the more
informed we are about studies case
studies like the one we see in New York
City the better we will be able to
defend the policies that we want to see
let's take a quick break make sure to
give the David Pakman show a like on
Facebook at facebook.com slash David
Pakman show very quick break and back
with much more right after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
okay as many of you know I am NOT a
socialist I am a social democrat that
probably doesn't come as a shock to
people who have been watching the show
or listening to the show for a while
Social Democrats are capitalists in the
sense that we are not trying to
overthrow capitalism and replace it with
socialism or Marxism or communism or
some system in which there's no more
private property private businesses etc
we recognize the many many many failings
of capitalism but we want to fix them
and one of the reasons that capitalism
has to be fixed is that it doesn't work
for tons of people but the interesting
thing about this is that if you want
some form of capitalism to remain you
had better damn well fix it because the
longer and longer it goes without
working for millions and millions and
millions of people it makes the system
more at risk of being overthrown by some
other system this was the concept in
fact of Marxism that eventually there
would be this uprising of the
proletariat that would take down the
bourgeoisie of course it has not
happened in the United States but the
worst capitalism is the more likely that
that becomes that gets us to today's
sort of news which is that case in point
there's a new poll which says seven out
of ten Millennials would vote for a
socialist candidate I do wonder whether
the people responding to the poll
actually know what socialism is because
it seems like lots of people talk about
socialism and they don't actually know
what it is but let's assume for a second
just for the sake of discussion because
the analysis is still an interesting one
this poll was released yesterday it
finds 70 percent of Millennials are
either somewhat or extremely likely to
vote for a socialist political candidate
50 percent of Millennials have a
somewhat or very unfavorable view of
capitalism which is up from last year
overall capitalism is still viewed more
favorably than other economic systems 61
percent positive but this is a very
clear
trendline even if many of these people
are mixing up socialism and social
democracy the trendline is clear and
this is why Social Democrats who are for
better regulated social capitalism need
to fix capitalism and by the way not
that I'm in the vulture capitalist
free-market lays affair type of camp if
you're a vulture capitalist and you want
to keep some form of capitalism this
should be a wake-up call for you as well
this is why you need to be fixing
capitalism with the socially democratic
reforms that people on the left of the
Democratic Party have been talking about
for many years the least damaging thing
to a capitalist is to fix capitalism or
they risk some other system actually
becoming something people really and
truly want you know when Donald Trump
says during his State of the Union we
will never be a capital of socialist
country he doesn't know that as I've
said before things change in countries
they can change slowly they can change
more quickly than sometimes we believe
is possible but the reality is that
there's no real risk right now of the
u.s. becoming actually socialist you
know college tuition paid through taxes
is not socialism Medicare for all isn't
socialism gun controls not socialism but
the right has both successfully and
unsuccessfully used the term socialism
as an argument to attack these socially
democratic policies but eventually
there's going to have to be some
accounting because as capitalism as we
know it continues to fail more and more
people and fail to provide a basic
standard of living and allow these just
sickening excesses of wealth to
accumulate more and more and more at the
top Millennials who see that system as
failing them why wouldn't they be open
to some other system they don't see all
of the great things that capitalism is
bringing them because it's arguably not
brought them a lot of great things so of
course they're going to look at
something else because our version of
capitalism is fundamentally broken so
you really want to tout the benefits of
capitalism and by this I mean some of
the main tenets right private property
private business ownership taxation
which tends to be progressive taxation
although you know different people argue
about how progressive it should be lots
of the things that we have if you want
to really make the case that it's
working you've got to make it work for
more people and that includes making
sure no one drops below a certain
standard of living that includes cutting
down on the corrosive influence of money
in politics and an influence peddling
the data is increasingly clear on this
something will have to be done or other
systems even misunderstood systems and
this is why I said you know a lot of
people don't know the different don't
realize what socialism actually is it
doesn't matter because no matter what
your assessment is of what capitalism is
and what socialism is if people
understand that the system as it exists
is not working for them it becomes
harder and harder to argue that this is
the system that we should keep in the
last 24 hours and I believe I know why I
received seven or eight emails asking me
to debate charlie Kirk okay if you don't
know who Charlie Kirk is I admire you
and I envy you Charlie Kirk is a
right-wing bomb thrower associated with
the right-wing group Turning Point USA
the whole premise of turning-point USA
as I understand it is that the left has
taken over our colleges the left has
taken over our universities and so what
T P USA or toilet paper USA is some no
it does is they go to colleges and
university and they say the universities
and they spout their bogus talking
points and they'll argue with people in
the crowd and you know sort of Ben
Shapiro like but not as rhetorically
skilled as ben shapiro candice owens is
another person associated with the group
if her name doesn't ring a bell
i double envy you not even being
involved in these toxic cesspools
congratulations so here's one example
email that i received um yesterday in
fact dear david charlie kirk needs to be
brought down every year someone from the
progressive media challenges him and
every year i know it's not going to go
well hassan [ __ ] looked like a
teenage Punk's saying fu to his
conservative father Sam cedar evaded
questions and looked easily fumbled and
ill-prepared and now Kyle kolinsky as
much as I love Kyle and think he does
great work I knew as soon as I saw the
announcement this was going to be bad
for reasons you yourself I'm sure
surmise so I won't go into them and sure
enough while goofy and funny and
throwing a few good punches I do not
think Kyle did well in his debate in
this debate he was visibly nervous kept
pacing around his podium evading
questions and letting Kirk ramble on his
sales pitch with no interruptions it's
like none of these people did their
homework to find out what Charlie's
talking points would be and just thought
Charlie Kirk that [ __ ] that liar yeah I
can take them on I know my stuff that's
why I know you would be different I know
it would take a lot of work but you
understand what it's going to take to
take down Charlie Kirk and I think
you're the only one with the disposition
to be able to do it you know his debate
tactics throw out a ton of misleading
facts and half-truths in a quick amount
of time knowing a few of them are bound
to stick he's got at least a dozen
shotgun shells of information ready to
go at a moment's notice he is not to be
underestimated he is really smart and
has an obvious good memory and you're
the only progressive I can think of that
can match him so I'm begging you David
for the sake of the progressive movement
that I see getting damaged every year by
this a-hole take this effort down you're
our only hope
says John so let's go through this in
pieces Charlie Kirk has debated at
politican Hasan [ __ ] last year Sam
cedar last year I believe
and Kyle kolinsky this year just a few
days ago I've not seen any of these
debates other than five minutes of
Hassan vs. Charlie in Los Angeles during
last year's politic on I saw the part
where Jen Kyogre Hassan's uncle was
yelling at Charlie from the audience and
otherwise it was just Charlie and Hasan
yelling at each other
I have no idea how the debate went with
Kyle over the weekend but what I'm
hearing is that people are saying Sam
Hassan and Kyle didn't debate well and
didn't look good and David you would do
better I don't know that I would do any
better I don't really have any reason to
think that I would do any better than
Sam
Hasaan or Kyle in the debate format I'm
flattered that John and a few other
people who emailed me think so I
actually think that the problem is the
debate format the political debate
format is either no moderator or you
know like a showpiece moderator who
doesn't really moderate with and this is
important a crowd that reacts to the
basest lowest common denominator talking
points and starts to interfere in the
debate so I believe the problem is the
debate because when one side cares about
facts Hassan and Sam and Kyle
generally speaking care about facts at
least as they see them right and the
other side cares about gotchas and
optics and kill shot moments and
repeating the same tired talking points
that are meaningless but they are
effective in front of a live audience
you were at a fundamental disadvantage
and so I don't know that I would do any
better in fact I may do worse because I
am more suited to a different type of
debate so to really debate these people
you need to be able to go in depth
without interruption from the audience
and without the next talking point D
railing everything you need a formal
controlled format that bores a lot of
audiences sadly it's not going to create
an event that will get politican to
shell out the checks of you know 10,000
15,000 25,000 dollars per invited
speaker or debater as they do now I
don't know if people know but you know
we get paid to go to Politico so would I
debate charlie Kirk I mean I guess maybe
would I do better than Kyle Sam and
Hasan if the format is the same I don't
know that I do any better but my focus
and you know I've said I have a story to
tell about me not being at politican
this year and a big piece of it was I
had this emergency appendectomy but
there is more to the story I'm really
trying to focus on the important stuff
and productive conversation I want to be
talking to people who have read
philosophy and political theory not
people who repeat the talking points
that Candice Owens feeds them right I
think if I'm making myself clear I think
that's the best way to it sort of
elucidate it let me know what you think
why engage in debates with bad faith
participants when the format will not
allow you to actually expose them for
the intellectual frauds
that they are let me know what you think
we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is
funny it's actually kind of good news
we've not heard from previously drunk
furious trump is jimmy from philly for a
while but he is requesting a name change
take a listen
David Jimmy from Philly yeah from now on
since I've stopped drinkin I demand you
referred to me as the furious psycho not
trumps my twitter it's a longer the
drunk Trump supportive because I'm not
drinking anymore
but they're psycho no it would be the
appropriate term
okay so Jimmy I don't know I I'm glad
that you're not drinking anymore because
the drinking was becoming a problem
Jimmy was having on some nights that he
would call into the live streams I don't
remember if it was four or six of like a
very high alcohol percentage IPA and
India Pale Ale for the uninitiated which
by the way who likes super hoppy beers
give me a break but that's a story for a
different day and I think they were like
eleven percent so he was having like
four to six which I believe is like
eight to twelve normal beers if a normal
beer is like five percent I think some
of those like you know water beers like
Bud Light or maybe even like two or
three percent this guy was putting down
a lot of alcohol so I'm glad that you're
not drinking I think psychonaut might be
a reference to the fact that Jimmy now
does LSD I don't know if that's a code
word for someone who does LSD but in any
case Jimmy seems more lucid when he
calls in and for that I think we can all
be grateful we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today
Democratic congressman Katie hill is
resigning because of allegations of
improper relationships with staffers we
will talk about that the police officer
who was told to tone down his gayness
their word not mine has been awarded
nineteen million dollars in a
discrimination lawsuit and a big gap a
chasm or chasm depending on something
has opened up on the issue of
reparations where seventy five percent
of African Americans support reparations
for slavery whereas only fifteen percent
of white Americans do according to a new
poll and we are going to dig in
- a lot of what is going on with that
issue on today's bonus show please get
today's bonus show the bonus show is for
members and patrons you can get instant
access at david pakman.com slash
membership or by becoming a patron at
the $5 a month or greater level at
patreon.com slash david package at
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]